kanye west is opening up about kobe
bryant like never before in the May
issue of GQ magazine the rapper calls
Kobe his best friend and explains why
his death was a game-changer
Kanye even notes that they were one and
the same saying quote he was the
basketball version of me and I was the
rap version of him and that's facts we
got the commercials that prove it no one
else can say this we came up at the same
time together in January Kobe his
daughter Gianna and seven others were
killed in a helicopter crash
Kanye shared that he often drives down
where the accident took place which
motivates him to live his life like the
late Laker legend quote the way that
Kobe would say that we all have to come
together and when this championship is
the way I look at life now to an
infinite other level this is a game
changer for me the 42 year old
acknowledged that he has a reputation
for screaming about things but notes
after Kobe's death he's not taking any
mess for an answer now in the magazine
Kanye doesn't hold back about his music
career either he admits he almost gave
it up because he was rapping for the
devil
during his Saint Pablo tour in 2016
the last thing Connie said on stage was
the show's over
the rapper said he felt like his mom Don
de who died in 2007 was talking through
him about achieving his highest purpose
quote my son is not just here to fill up
these sports arenas my son's got
something else to do and things have
changed since then
Kanye took his talents from the sports
arenas to church for his Sunday services
following Kobe's death the rapper hosted
an emotional midnight Sunday service to
pay tribute to the NBA star he even
freestyled a verse in honor of his
friend also on stage that night chance
the rapper who had to fight back tears
while performing his song with Kanye
ultralight beam
[Music]
et talked to Kanye in 2016 after Kobe's
last NBA game and he was smiling from
ear to ear after watching his friend
dominate the court for the last time
ganya how incredible was that great that
was great
[Music]